a good afternoon everyone I'm frame
Chandra roller I work for n gore
Mathematica engineering department here
at Wolfram today we are going to go over
financial data feeds in Wolfram language
and we have this platform called Wolfram
finance platform and as something
similar to in philosophy like
programming lab and Wolfram desktop is
but it's more focused towards finance
industry if you are in an investment
firm or some your students are doing
financial data doing statistics on them
then this is a good solution in that
case and so what we'll go over today is
the current functionality of Wolfram
finance platform then we'll discuss
about the upcoming data feeds that is
more resources that will hook up to for
financial data then targeted audiences
so it's basically the current
functionality right now is we hook up to
Bloomberg terminal and what it is is
just Bloomberg supplying all sorts of
data they have more than 30 to 40,000
financial fields and hundreds and
thousands of instruments that you can
get data for and when you get fun as
platform you have CUDA functionality
also the CUDA link is obviously
available throughout our product line
but here the CUDA also hooks up to
financial derivatives and
as we go further we'll go where
Bloomberg terminal bloomberg data
license and Reuters these are the three
different API source resources that you
can get data from the targeted audiences
usually it's a very niche product in a
way I it's useful directed to various
financial institution and academia and
we do supply provide premium technical
support if you have Wolfram von us
platform I think you receive enterprise
support without and then we also have
website and you can go to that website
and get further more information for
sales and other things so these are what
will cover as we go along current
interface what you can get now then
we'll discuss about the new data feeds
the existing entity value interface and
2d deploy which is not finalized yet
asynchronous execution this is a way to
receive data from these resources and
we'll cover that so right now this is
the product that is out there you can
use it with Bloomberg terminal and so
this is what it looks like right now you
connect to a resource over here it is
boom berg desktop api which is
bloomberg's real-time data API if you
have a subscription for them you can
hook it up and you can actually get
market data real-time market data with
this and so you do market interconnect
you get a market data cells and so
you're in business to actually get data
and with Bloomberg you have different
aspects of getting the data
you can get snapshot which is basically
one value or multiple values but it's
just static you is the latest it's here
so this is how it works so you do a
market data sure is that good or bigger
Oh 200 okay Wow okay it looks very
interesting on my screen that okay and
so here here's the syntax forward market
data got you want a snapshot here are
the instruments IBM equity Apple equity
fields our current market capital and
loss price so these are the fields you
can get and the output of that looks
something like this initially its onward
Oh what is that that's too much but it
has old values and you can we have these
and it was really nice with great so now
you have something that it looks rather
nice is what is the ID market cap on so
we have that functionality then you can
get historical data market day to get we
give it a date range instruments fields
so if I were to evaluate that and we get
to market data table with all the
information there then we can do also
real-time subscriptions and the way it
works is first you start the market eat
it is you create an object event
delivery pass through so everything that
goes through sold the data and the
instrument is euro USD cuz a bit of
gloss price or the trigger feel so your
data is going to get updated when either
of these three fields are updated and
the market so here you get the
subscription
and then there is another step market
data subscription starts ooh ok we
started it and now we can look at a
particular field so and I can do dynamic
of thought and so you'll see it updating
the second of that so this is currently
this is available you can buy it you can
use it and people do use it ok so now we
are going to get into what's coming so
these are the new data fees bloomberg
data license Reuters ultra performance
UPA that's also called you PA so why
bloomberg data lights and why do we
introduce that so the idea is that the
licensing terms from bloomberg data
license and licensing is an issue in
financial industry so i have to talk
about it so here the bloomberg data
license you can get it in corporation
and you can deploy it in your private
cloud and in your company folks can use
it Bloomberg terminal is tied to a
machine the data cannot leave the
machine you cannot share the data with
anybody you can't have automated reports
and send it to folks in your company you
cannot do that and Bloomberg is very
clear when you have the Bloomberg
terminal when you started it's very
clear that thus the extent of your
sharing of data the machine but with
bloomberg data license it's more relaxed
because it is not real time and company
wide access and it's compatible with
wolfram private cloud so you can deploy
it in if
and the private cloud you can access
this it works over HTTP protocol there's
calendar data which we'll talk a little
bit later about okay and Reuters ultra
performance API it's still TCP protocol
they have raters of their own protocol
of exchanging data between your computer
you get historical data snapshot of
class real-time access similar to
Bloomberg but perhaps a little bit
cheaper I'm not sure on the prices of
that so you've seen the old interface of
market data table market data get but we
wanted to integrate it in existing
functionality so entity value framework
is pretty nice for that and entity if
you have ever used entity value it works
really nice with time series and it
returns quantities which is pretty
useful when you're coding so entity
framework is there it has been there
since 2014 we might go over the
documentation of that also but okay so
this is something what we have been
working on and here's the syntax for how
to get the last price of microsoft and
how it looks an entity value framework
so here I can deploy it and I get a nice
quantity and essays US dollars then you
can do it with entity value of multiple
fields here here's a blur equity and you
get a simple list and previously if you
remember when we were asking for
historical data we would get a table a
market data table now the first step
whenever you get a historical data
there are too many numbers it's not very
useful you're going to do something else
with that data you're most likely going
to use it so here are the two times you
just get time series directly you don't
have to go through an extra extra step
to do that and you can do a dateless
plot of the odd so pretty quick to do
that and you can get it in different
forms also so the entity value has
annotations and what that means is this
so here I'm giving multiple instruments
Microsoft and Vodafone and the fields
are lost price and ask price and so it's
in an association and everything is
properly labeled and if you look at the
data set sorry about this there is some
issue we here where it thinks Microsoft
queries the internet for it but it's it
makes it slow but here it is so it looks
pretty you can make really nice reports
if you're using other if you're using a
reboot mechanism and wanted to present
it now this we are using with Bloomberg
terminal it is it is in currently that's
the way it is but we could think about
it sorry
so then you would be depending on
implicitly figuring out what resource it
is because when we will go further
you'll notice that px lost is unique to
Bloomberg so you have to say this
property belongs to Bloomberg otherwise
you probably could but I'd like to move
on for now and here's the property
Association where if you're just
interested in
okay and here we are grouping with
fields all right so now we'll talk about
so that was Bloomberg terminal now we
which existed in market data framework
and here we are talking about Reuters
ultra performance API so I'd like to
show this particular diagram how we
interact with all these external AP is a
lot of time these api's are in C so you
go to Reuters and they say we have a
capi you go to Bloomberg and they say we
have a capi and how do we hook it up to
Mathematica and we use this technology
library link and it is well documented
so you guys have access to it all set
and often in financial industry what
happens is you have your own see
solution C++ solutions and if you want
to get older data in Mathematica if
you'd use either Wolfram protocol
lighting is symbolic transfer protocol
WS DP or wolfram library link and
basically you create a dll and then you
talk to that dl early the colonel talks
to the dll right so that was the what I
wanted to get over with and again here
we have this particular is nothing
different than what we were looking in
the previous lies entity value now here
you notice the instruments have changed
it's no longer msft us equity now this
becomes roight is specific and so this
is called Ric Ric Reuters code recruited
instrument code I think it stands for
and you can evaluate that and you'll get
a quantity
and quantities are useful because if
you're working with different markets in
London and in us together you want in
otherwise you'll get confused Vodafone
London equity without pull us equity one
as 200 pounds and otherwise $100 so it's
useful to have those things and another
example of here I'm doing water phone
and and going forward we are doing
something called asynchronous execute
this will become more interesting when
we talk about bloomberg data license but
the idea is sample it returns
immediately you don't wait for it so the
syntax is very similar to URL submit
which was introduced in 11 oh and it is
asynchronous execute of entity value
then because it's happening is
synchronously you want to have handler
functions data received and how Lucas
what it will do is we generate an event
called data received when that event is
generated we do a print but what is
going to be printed thus defined in
handler function keys so data when we
receive data that's what's going to be
printed so let's execute that and it
creates an asynchronous task object and
if you have ever used your all submit or
your fetch asynchronous which has been
there for quite some time you'll miss
I'm sorry what yes it will be across yes
yes so if we look at the messages here's
the message 5714 that's what it got
printed let me delete that
and this is a bit more involved example
of red so let me explain what I'm going
to try to do here I'm going to receive
bid and ask price of a particular
instrument and plot it thus that's the
shorter and i'll define the handler
function so whenever an event is
received this is my handler function
this is going to get executed whenever
an event is the here it is collect data
received all I'm doing is if the field
is ask append to an ask list if the
field is bed append to bed nothing fancy
and
so here I'm asking for aunt Ida value
Reuters UPA enter the property f1 is
then I'm going to evaluate is going to
be bed and f 1 i'm going to call this
when the data is is if i want to execute
collect data received and because the
sploo that means i have to evaluate that
first okay so and continuous goes to
true means i want to stream this data so
it's not just going to do one go and
stop so I've started this dream
so the Oscars do 25 over here Oh God
okay I know what mistake I did I ask for
vodafone the markets over there are
closed I'm going to skip the so sorry
about that that's not nice
ok
okay I real just simply going to forget
that happened so now we are going to go
back to asynchronous execute and save
all right
this particular now we are talking about
Bloomberg retail license I just have to
tell you this if i were to execute this
particular call
you
it takes about two minutes what is
happening is it goes to the server
server takes time and it's about two
minutes because bloomberg data license
API is a slow API it's not real time so
here's I'm just going to make a quick
handler function as I've spoken about
and here I'm going to execute this again
it's similar syntax to you all submit
and it returns immediately so now you
have a scheduled task object and we can
yes right so
okay so here's what you're getting
you're getting a particular message code
100 description data is not available
yet to try again later so we're just
going to keep trying again and so what
is happening is this this is how the
bloomberg data license API works you ask
the ape Bloomberg service that you want
a Microsoft time series immediately
you'll get a response a okay your
request was good here's the response ID
and the next time you want the data
present this response ID and will give
you the data and so we give them
immediately the response ID and then it
tells us as you just saw try again later
so we want to do that asynchronous if we
just don't want to keep waiting and hold
the colonel up and not be able to do
anything for two minutes so we just do
it asynchronously and once the data is
there then you're not holding up the
colonel you have already used it so here
it is so I've started it and now looking
at the dynamic the data is the time
series and you have successfully
received the data and you can
get a quick time series forward okay now
this is entity deploy what happened the
one thing that Bloomberg does provide
you is that you can have a calendar data
you can tell the server you can make a
request one time it was put it on the
Bloomberg server which says give me the
last price every day so you don't have
to wait at all you just come in in the
morning and the office and you just
retrieve that task and this is what
you'll create the task as entity deploy
it's very similar to cloud deploy which
lives in the cloud here it will live on
the Bloomberg server here you are asking
every day give me the Microsoft's
closing price in this case is P X los
and well this is a time time series over
here so date interval is 2006 sorry this
is year-to-date data and do it daily
every day you want this data and when
you get this data print and what kind of
data you'd like task data and response
data similar to what we saw now I had
already run this but it will remain
there between Colonel sessions so I'd
run that earlier and it saved it and is
it
so it's not responding
I was told to hook it up with the wire
and I did and this is the result anyway
so the idea is that you will receive the
data and it will live in a file and
every time you open it it's not going to
hold up anything you'll just receive
data from data license API and it will
be as rich data as you get from
Bloomberg terminal and so i'll give you
why I was doing remote into a machine on
the Wolfram headquarters is because all
this thing requires a lot of machinery
and laws of authentication and they
don't like people using laptops and then
so as I was saying the licensing issues
are quite hard with these financial data
anyways okay I that's all I've got oh
thank you for your patience
[Applause]